foreign
Alex is in North Carolina hi Alex
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi John thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up
Dave to quote you I've been looking good
with no freaking money
and I've been doing it for years uh I
just discovered your work and I've been
following it I'm on baby steps number
two
and basically since I discovered your
work Dave I mean from one day to the
next everything I bought and all all my
decisions for my reckless spending and
my bad decisions now just feels weird
and and sort of brings shame I mean I'm
driving around in the new car I bought
last year it feels weird sitting in the
expensive furniture doesn't feel right
um things I've I've bought and stuff
just makes me feel uncomfortable uh
pretty much all because I know I have
this big mess to clean up
um I think I'll be able to clean up the
mess and come out all right but I guess
my question is twofold or my number is
right and that I can clean this mess up
without changing my lifestyle too much
if I can just control my spending
behavior and secondly if I can clean it
up with my current income how do I deal
with it sort of emotionally and
psychologically kind of seeing all my
past mistakes every day in front of me
okay uh well how much debt do you have
not counting your house
80 000. okay and what is that on
uh forty thousand is my car uh thirty
thousand is uh student loan and ten
thousand is a credit card okay and what
do you make
uh uh 150 okay and how much money do you
have in savings not counting retirement
about 15K non-retirement any
non-retirement Investments at all
about 5k
5K mutual fund
okay so we got 20K there all right cool
cool
um
I think it can be done by October one
yeah yeah maybe
if he sells that car yeah sell the car
and use the 20K yeah you'll be done by
Christmas yeah
so yeah this is very doable
um if you don't sell the car you'll be
done by the next Christmas
so okay um 18 months you know 6 to 18
months you can be done depending on
whether you want to keep the car or not
um and I think it was it you I think you
were talking about somebody the other
day was saying your stuff talks to you
oh yeah was that you yeah um uh don
Madsen the minimalist mom was was
introduced me to this idea that
um your things have imaginary
conversations with you all the time and
I kind of rolled my eyes when she said
it and then I got home
and I started looking around my basement
where I've got this little Jam area and
my hunting gear and all my books
and they quietly started saying hey are
you going to read us are you going to be
stupid Forever my guitars are like are
you just not going to play us just going
to be old you're gonna be that guy and
my hunting stuff was like he's going to
be an indoor nerd now it wouldn't shut
up and so there is a an idea that at
some point I gotta get rid of some of
this crap and I gotta deal with this
shame right I'm interested brother what
makes you feel this shame like you keep
talking about you don't feel comfortable
on this what is at the root of that
discomfort
know that it was like Reckless Behavior
um that I sort of see the light now and
yeah what if I just say sell it
what's your initial response like put on
today on Facebook Marketplace here is
some furniture I'm going to sell it
what's your instant gut response
peace what are you doing man sell it
yeah sell it
are you single
uh I'm married okay yeah you probably
okay yeah
you gotta lead with that man before you
saw her couch we need to talk about this
but yeah
um so it's okay if you're uh
I mean I I have okay I owned a bunch of
property before I went bankrupt in my
20s
uh most of those houses are still
standing
so when I go out to eat and that end of
town and we drive by and go yeah I used
to own that and that house is looking at
me going yeah back when you were stupid
and that's been 35 or 40 years ago you
know and so that house is still telling
me I'm stupid or was stupid but I was
stupid back then and so you know when
you bought that you were Reckless
and it's telling you you you're you were
Reckless back then and it might be okay
if it's not weird or dysfunctional to
think have a few things reminding you
not to go back to that behavior that you
know that table says we shouldn't have
bought that and and so
um and and you know every time I eat at
it I remember not to be Reckless anymore
right so maybe it's a good reminder in a
sense a milestone a psychological or
spiritual Milestone to look but if
there's too many of these things telling
you you're stupid all day long it's the
thing is you have to make the items
behave in their message their message
has to be you used to be Reckless when
you bought me now you're not
the old me did that but the new me
doesn't do that and so if they're but if
they're telling you that you're just
you're stupid no it was stupid when I
bought you but I'm not stupid now and I
wouldn't I wouldn't buy you again and
here's what you have to do you have to
gain some confidence in this new life
and our buddy Alex hermosi I love the
way he says this to get confident you
have to practice you just gotta you
can't think your way to being confident
yeah you have to start doing it so you
need to start making a budget with your
wife every month and what you're going
to do is you're going to look up in six
months and you're gonna you're gonna owe
nobody anything you're gonna have gotten
rid of some of this stuff that's
nonsense and she might be completely at
peace or she may have like want to pull
your hair out but
there's going to be some peace in your
house and then you're going to have some
confidence because you've got some
budgeting practice you're starting to
get a hang of this thing and all of a
sudden this shame kind of evaporates
because you're walking a little bit
taller and you've leaned into this life
right you know and honestly the thing
that Craig Rochelle and James Clear both
talk a lot about too is resetting your
identity yeah and that's saying okay I
am a person who is thoughtful and wise
in my purchases I'm not a reckless
person
and that's you say that's who I am now
now I used to be you know this and this
and this and I used to be the guy who
borrowed money up his eyeballs I said I
went broken and so I'll start doing this
whole thing right that's me but I'm not
that guy anymore yeah I'm now mister
don't borrow money Ramsay I mean come on
hello and there's something about
sitting with your wife and saying here's
who we're gonna be are you in and then
y'all just reverse engineer and you
co-create that life together yeah and I
think your stuff will shut up when you
do that it does it'll it'll quit yelling
at you it's only yelling at you if it
gets a foothold I have one guitar that
still yells at me but all the others are
good they're all good well I you know
what
Facebook Marketplace nope nope